Venom's massive success at the box office
made a sequel virtually guaranteed.
Confirmed details are all but nonexistent
at this point, but rumors and spoilers have
already started leaking — so here's a look
at what we can reasonably expect from Venom
2.
If you were waiting for Woody Harrelson to
show up in Venom, then you had to wait until
the mid-credits for a brief scene.
Presumably returning to his career as an investigative
journalist, Eddie Brock is summoned to San
Quentin, where Harrelson waits in a cage.
Everything about the scene feels like the
foundation for a sequel, and in May 2018,
Harrelson confirmed he'd be showing up in
Venom 2.
If you're a Marvel Comics fan, then the hints
about Woody Harrelson's role in Venom's mid-credits
scene weren't real subtle.
In the comics, Venom's symbiote species reproduces
asexually, and Venom's own symbiote spawn
had the horrible idea of bonding to serial
killer Cletus Kasady.
The result was the villain Carnage.
He's tougher than Venom and has a body count
to rival the Joker's.
Even though no one in the mid-credits scene
says his name -- with Harrelson's curly red
wig, the fact that he's a convicted serial
killer, his penchant for writing in blood,
and of course his closing line--
"When I get outta here…and I will..."
There's gonna be carnage."
-- the signs point pretty hard to Venom's
bad guy having a bit more red coloring in
the second movie.
Considering the nature of the character, it's
surprising Venom didn't earn an R rating.
According to producer Avi Arad, Venom 2 won't
be R either.
That's an even a bigger surprise with the
likelihood of Carnage's involvement in the
sequel.
But Arad doesn't think you need an R rating
to do Carnage justice.
He told Collider,
"It's not about what he does because we never
have to show the knife going from here to
there."
The Venom producer described Cletus Kasady
as a soul filled with torment, and that he
wants audiences to be able to feel for him.
Sympathetic villains can certainly sell; the
success Tom Hiddleston found as the MCU's
Loki is proof of that.
And Venom supports what Arad says about not
having to show all the violence on the screen.
For example, we know Venom eats villains in
the film, though we never actually see him
do it.
We'll see if the filmmakers can do likewise
with Carnage.
But if the comics are any indication, they're
going to need to kill a lot of people off-screen
-- a lot.
To comic book purists, divorcing Venom's movie
origin from Spider-Man may have been more
painful than a symbiote being ripped from
its host, but Venom director Ruben Fleischer
seems fairly sure the current live-action
versions of both characters will collide on-screen
eventually.
Speaking to ScreenRant, Fleischer said,
"I'd love to see [Venom] face off against
Spider-Man at some point.
It feels like that's inevitable."
Fleischer went on to say he knew that both
Tom Hardy and Tom Holland were excited about
the prospect, and that he didn't know whether
or not that would mean Venom would or could
become part of the MCU.
So is it possible we could we see this inevitable
clash in Venom 2?
It's an enticing possibility, especially if
Carnage proves to be the sequel's villain.
In the comics Spider-Man, Venom, and Carnage
have always worked as an interesting trio
of combatants, particularly with Venom sometimes
flip-flopping between allies.
It's enough to make you want to imagine that
the sequel to Venom might be titled Venom:
Maximum Carnage.
Considering Venom's record-breaking success,
you'd think the director could name his own
price to helm the sequel.
But Variety pointed out that it looks like
Venom director Ruben Fleischer won't be able
to direct Venom 2, whether he wants to or
not.
Fleischer directed 2009's post-apocalyptic
comedy Zombieland and in July 2018 Sony confirmed
the production of Zombieland 2 with pretty
much all of the original's stars returning
— as well as Fleischer, who's set to direct
the sequel.
If Fleischer is going to be busy directing
Zombieland 2, then it could be difficult if
not impossible for him to also direct Venom
2.
The Variety article didn't offer any hints
about who, if anyone, Sony might be considering
to replace Fleischer.
It could be that — since both franchises
are under Sony's tent — the studio is trying
to find a way to facilitate Fleischer helming
both projects before fishing for a successor.
Considering Harrelson will probably be playing
Carnage in Venom 2 as well as appearing in
Zombieland 2, maybe he and Fleischer could
just… carpool or something.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Marvel movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.